looks like it's a certainty we are going
to have an election because that's what
the Labour Party have decided their
Shadow Cabinet let's get more from
scotch operator in Downing Street Tom
you've had a comment put out by Jeremy
Corbyn what he said to the shadow
cabinets in the last hour is that he's
consistently said he's ready for an
election and the support is subject to a
no deal breaks it being off the table
that is now off the table he said
because of that extension we will now
launch the most ambitious of radical
campaign for real change our country has
ever seen we understand Labour MPs have
received a message saying that there is
a heavy three line width for today's
votes in Parliament and that Labour will
support any date that is put forward so
the date that is currently on the
government's bill is the 12th of
December but if an amendment were to be
brought by the Liberal Democrats all the
SNP to changed that day either to the
9th or the 10th or the 11th labour would
back that to so in effect Adam the
significance is that Labour is
confirming their support to general
election before Christmas which means
that it is now looks like it's
completely on ok thank you very much
indeed
Tom Rayner so that's the news there will
be an election in the second week of
December all main parties now supporting
it lots more coming up here on Sky News